ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BACKER BOARD YES BRADFORD
CABALLERO CORTES DE DALLY DODD
DORADO EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZ
GROWS HERTZBERG HUESO HER TADO
JONES KAMLAGER LAYERED LEYVA
WITH MON MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN
NEWMAN NIELSEN A TELEPHONE PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI.
WIENER WILK. MEMBERS OF A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. WHAT THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BE ON
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE WILL BEGIN LED
IN PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR CORTESE AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WHEN WE
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. BY
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THIS IS KNOWN AS THE
PER SEAT TO RESERVE ABA. TODAY
MAY THERE BE PEACE WITHIN. MAY
YOU TRUST YOUR HIGHEST POWER
BUT YOU ARE EXACTLY WHERE YOU
ARE MEANT TO BE. MAY YOU NOT
FORGET THE INFINITE
POSSIBILITIES THAT ARE BORN OF
FAITH. MAY YOU USE THOSE GIFTS
THAT YOU HAVE RECEIVED AND PASS
ON THE LOVE THAT HAS BEEN GIVEN
TO YOU. MAY YOU BE CONTENT
KNOWING THAT YOU WERE A
CREATION OF GOD. LET THIS
PRESENCE SETTLE INTO YOUR BONES
AND ALLOW YOUR SOUL THE FREEDOM
TO SING AND DANCE. RESERVE FOR
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU AMEN.
M. AND. PLEASE RUN RENDER
PROPER HONORS I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. THIS
AMERICAN THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH
IT STANDS ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. MEMBERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION OUR FIRST
ORDER OF BUSINESS WILL BE
CONSIDERATION OF THE BUDGET
BILL- THERE ARE A NUMBER OF. K.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO GET DONE TODAY SO I'D LIKE-
YOUR COOPERATION IF WE COULD-
WE'RE GOING TO BE CONSIDERING
THE BUDGET BUDGET BILL PACKAGE
BUT BEFORE WE PROCEED WE WILL
MOVE TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
FOR PROCEDURAL PURPOSES. CENTER
SKINNER ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
YOUR PROCEDURAL MOTION YES I AM
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- IF I
VOTE SORRY GO AHEAD. THE
FOURTEENTH DAY OF THREE I KNOW
I MAKE MOST OKAY- MEMBERS I
MOVE TO SUSPEND THE SENATE
RULES AS THEY RELATE TO
ASSEMBLY BILLS ONE THIRTY FOUR
ONE THIRTY SIX. 381-381-4011
431-405-1409. ONE FIFTY ONE
FIFTY ONE AND ONE FIFTY SEVEN.
PLEASE SENATE ELSON. IF YOU
DON'T ALL RIGHT WE'LL GET THE
MIKE ON FOR YOU YES SIR YES I'M
NOT PRESENT LADIES ON THE
SENATE I REQUESTED THE ROLL
CALL VOTE AND ASK FOR A NOBLE
VERY GOOD BROKE UP PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA.
HI ATKINS. AYE BATES. NO BACKER.
HI PORGES NO BRADFORD HI CUT BY
ADAM HI PROTESTING HI DALLY NO
DODD. HI THERE ALSO I EGGMAN HI
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH.
GROVE. NO HERTZBERG HI HUESO.
HURTADO HI JONES NO KAMLAGER HI
LAYERED I LEYVA FIVE LIMóN HI
MCGUIRE. HI MELENDEZ. NO MAN. I
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. NO A SHOW
OF BOTH NO HAN HI PORTANTINO
FIVE ROTH AYE RUBIO HI SKINNER
HI STERN HI I'M BURKE. HI WHY
CASKEY I WIENER I WILK NO.
HUESO HI. HIGHS THIRTY ONE
KNOWS NINE. THE SENATE RULES
ARE SUSPENDED. MEMBERS ARE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE BUDGET
BILLS WILL TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR. SENATOR SKINNER
BATUM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY FOUR
BY TE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET CENTERS SKINNER
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS HE- AB
ONE THIRTY FOUR IS THE MENTAL
HEALTH TRAILER BILL. IT
PROVIDES COUNTIES WITH AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR OF FLEXIBILITY
ON REPORTING AND EXPENDITURES
FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT WHICH IS PROP SIXTY THREE
AND PROVIDING FUNDING FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES DUE TO
THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY
THIRTY STANDS THE TIME FRAME
FOR REPORTING ON THREE YEAR
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE
EXPENDITURE PLANS KICKSTAND TO
BUY AN ADDITIONAL YEAR. IT
ALLOWS ACCESS TO COUNTY PRUDENT
RESERVES OF PROP SIXTY THREE
PINES TO FUND MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES FOR AN ADDITIONAL YEAR
ADDED AUTHORIZES COUNTIES
FLEXIBILITY TO DETERMINE
ALLOCATIONS OF PROP SIXTY THREE
FINES WITHIN REQUIRED
EXPENDITURE CATEGORIES FOR AN
ADDITIONAL YEAR. ADDED
ADDITIONALLY APPROPRIATES
FEDERAL COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
PLANS THAT WERE WARDED UNDER
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN I'M
WITHOUT. MEMBERS I ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE. MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
TO OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SINGMAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES.
HI BAKER FIVE FORGES HI
BRADFORD. I HAVE A ADAM HI
CORTESE. HI DALLY HI DODD HI
THERE ARE SO. HI EGGMAN. HI
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG HI HUESO HI HER
TADO HI JONES. HI KAMLAGER HI
LAYERED HI LEYVA HI LIMóN HI
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ HI MEN. HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN HI A CHIRLA
BOTH HI PAM HI PORTANTINO HI
ROTH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
STERN HI I'M BURKE. HI WHITE
HOUSE SKI HI WIENER AYE WILK HI
HIGHS FORTY NO ZERO THE BUDGET-
BILL IS APPROVED MEMBERS I WANT
TO ASK IF YOU WANT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION THAT YOU GO TO THE
BACK BECAUSE IT'S REALLY LOUD
APPEAR AND I KNOW IT'S REALLY
EXCITING TO SEE EACH OTHER UP
CLOSE. FOR A CHANGE. THE PEOPLE
I'M TALKING TO ARE NOT
LISTENING SO PLEASE WE'RE GOING
TO TRY TO GET THROUGH ALL OF
OUR BUDGET BILLS TODAY
EXPEDITIOUSLY. SENATOR SKINNER
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL ONE THIRTY SEVEN BY THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN
ACT RELATED TO STATE GOVERNMENT
AND MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL WROTE IT
RELATED TO THE BUDGETS. CENTER
SKINNER THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANKS SO MUCH- AB ONE THIRTY
SEVEN IS THE GENERAL GOVERNMENT
BUDGET TRAILER BILL. AND IT
MAKES TECHNICAL STATUTORY
CHANGES TO IMPLEMENT THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGET ACT. FOR GENERAL
GOVERNMENT OPERATIONS AND STATE
ADMINISTRATION. MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A GRANT PROGRAM AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES. TO SUPPORT VICTIMS OF
HATE CRIMES AND SUPPORT CRIME
PREVENTION EFFORTS. AND IT IS
CHALLENGES A NEW ENERGY UNIT AT
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
BUSINESS AND DEVELOPMENT. TO
ACCELERATE THE PLANNING
FINANCING AND EXECUTION OF%
CRITICAL ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS. SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. YES SENATOR NIELSEN
MONOPOD LADIES ON THE SENATE I
URGE A NO VOTE ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS HERE IS CREATING MORE
DEPARTMENTS OF STATE GOVERNMENT
WE DO NOT NEED THOSE AND I
WOULD URGE A NO VOTE. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SENATOR SKINNER YOU MAKE
INCLUDE LAST YEAR I VOTE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
FIVE ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS AYE
BATES. BAKER ARE YOU PORGES.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI CORTES
E. HI DALLY NO DODD. HI THERE
ARE SO HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. HERTZBERG I
HUESO. HI HER TADO HI JONES.
KAMLAGER FIVE LAYERED FIVE
LEYVA. HI THE MON. HI MCGUIRE
HI MELENDEZ. MAN HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN NO A CHIRLA BOTH HI PAN
FIVE PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI STERN HI
I'M BURKE HI WHITE HOUSE STEVE
HI WIENER. HI WELL. NOW PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES.
GORGEOUS HIGH. GROWTH JONES.
MELENDEZ HI. BYE BYE THIRTY
FORD KNOWS THREE THE BUDGET
BILLS APPROVED MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN. I
SAID MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY
EIGHT BY THE COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET CENTER SKINNER THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANKS SO MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB ONE THIRTY
EIGHT IS THE LABOR AND EMPLOYEE
COMPENSATION BILL TRAILER BILL.
MOST SIGNIFICANTLY THIS
REQUIRES EDT TO PROVIDE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
CLAIMANTS THE OPTION TO RECEIVE
PAYMENTS VIA DIRECT DEPOSIT TO
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR AND REQUIRES EDT TO
PROVIDE REAL TIME LANGUAGE
ACCESS SERVICES BY
INTERPRETERS- BILINGUAL STAFF
BEYOND THE TRANSLATION OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE ONLINE
INTERFACE BY SPECIFIC DATES IT
EXTENDS THE SUNSET DATE FOR THE
ENHANCED DISABILITY INSURANCE
AND PAID FAMILY LEAVE WAGE
REPLACEMENT. THROUGH JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND
IT APPROPRIATES ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION IN PROP TO FUNDS TO
MAKE A SUPPLEMENTAL PENSION
PAYMENT TO CALPERS UNFUNDED
LIABILITY AND SIX HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN MILLION PROP TO FIND
PAYMENT ON BEHALF OF EMPLOYEES
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE EMPLOYEE RETIREE HEALTH PRE
FINDING THAT WAS SUSPENDED.
LAST YEAR. THERE WERE THAT I
ALSO AYE VOTE. FOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SINGMAN PLEASE CALL THE US
SENATOR EYES I'M SORRY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST WANT TO-
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THIS I
JUST WANT TO SAY A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS ON THE STOCK IT ON THE
E. D. D. EVERYBODY WORKED
REALLY HARD ON TRYING TO. FIX
THE FIX THE ISSUES BUT WE CAN'T
LEAVE IT OUT THERE WE HAVE TO
KEEP IN WE HAVE TO KEEP
INVESTING SO I JUST WENT REMIND
US OF THAT I ALSO WANT TO.
POINT OUT THE GARMENT WORKER
WAGE CLAIM PILOT PROGRAM WHERE
CURRENTLY THERE ARE ABOUT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN UNPAID WAGE
CLAIMS BUT ONLY SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE- IN THE
FUND TO PAY THEM AND WE HAVE TO
MAKE UP FOR THAT AND THIRD I
WANNA ALSO SAY I'M VERY PROUD.
THAT WE ARE DEFINING THE HIGH
ROAD MODEL IN STATUTE TO MAKE
SURE THAT OUR FUNDS HAVE
STANDARDS AND CRITERIA THE LEAD
TO GOOD PAYING JOBS THANK YOU
MANAGER. THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATE
NIELSEN BETTER PRESENT LATER
DOWN THE SENATE I DO URGE AN
AYE VOTE ON THIS BUT I WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE THIS IS
INSUFFICIENT REFORM OF BDD BUT
THOSE REFORMS ARE GOING TO BE
MORE FORTHCOMING AND SUBSEQUENT
LEGISLATION SO I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO BY THE END OF SESSION
GET RID OF SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
AT THAT. VERY DYSFUNCTIONAL
AGENCY BUT THIS BILL IS A SMALL
STEP BUT IT IS NOT SUFFICIENT.
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SAYING NINE PLEASE BOB-
SENATOR SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THANK YOU I. S. ZERO
VOTE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BAKER FIVE LARGEST.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI COURT
HI DALLY NO DODD HI THERE ARE
SO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HI GROVE. HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO. HI FURTADO HI JONES
NO KAMLAGER HI LAYERED I LEYVA
HI LIMóN HI MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ NO MAN. HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. FIVE A CHIRLA BOTH. HI
PAN AYE PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI STERN HI
I'M BURKE HI WHITE HOUSE SKI HI
WIENER AYE WILK NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES
GORGEOUS. GROVE NOW. HIGHS
THIRTY THREE KNOWS FIVE THE
BUDGET BILL IS APPROVED MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY EIGHT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY ONE BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
CANNABIS AND MAKING
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET CENTER SKINNER
THE FOR YEARS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB
1-409-401-1401 IS THE CANNABIS
BUDGET TRAILER BILL WHICH
ESTABLISHES THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL AND
CONSOLIDATES THE EXISTING
CANNABIS LICENSE ENTITIES INTO
A SINGLE ENTITY AND THE
EXISTING ONES NOW ARE UNDER THE
BUREAU OF CANNABIS CONTROL
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD KNACK IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
INSTEAD THEY WILL ALL BE PART
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
CONTROL. THE BILL ALSO
ESTABLISHES THE FRAMEWORK FOR
CANNABIS TREAT SAMPLES EXTENDS
THE PROVISIONAL PROGRAM SUNSET
DATE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY SIX AND THE PROVISIONAL
LICENSES WOULD OTHERWISE SUNSET
AT THE END OF THIS YEAR ON
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
HOWEVER WITH THE EXTENSION IT
ALSO ESTABLISHES TANGIBLE GOAL
POSTS FOR LICENSEES TO ACHIEVE
CERTAIN BENCHMARKS WHILE THEY
ARE UNDERGOING THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL COMPLIANCE. THE
TEN OF THE BILL IS NOT TO
DISRUPT AGREEMENTS THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE MADE WITH
THE STATE TO COMPLY WITH SYKORA
AND IT ITS INTENT IS TO HELP
THE PROVISIONAL LICENSEES MOVED
INTO ANNUAL LICENSURE SO ON
THIS NOTE THERE'S BEEN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND WE'VE
ALREADY MADE SOME AGREEMENTS
AND TO LET. OUR OTHER HOUSE TO
MAKE SOME CHANGES IN THE CLEAN
UP TRAILER BILL INCLUDING FOR
SUBSEQUENT RENEWALS AFTER JULY-FIRST TWENTY TWENTY THREE THERE
IS CLARIFICATION ON HOW TO
DEMONSTRATE COMPLIANCE WITH
SEQUEL FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
THAT HAVE MADE AGREEMENTS ON
DOT COMPLIANCE THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY ENVISIONED WITHIN THE
BILL BEFORE US. AND WILL ADD
LANGUAGE IF SECRET IS COMPLETE
THAT THEY ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
COMPLY WITH THE SEQUEL
BENCHMARKS IN THIS BILL. AND
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
SENATOR HIM ON. THANK YOU AT IT
MEMBERS AT THIS IS A IF THE
TRAILER BILL THAT'S DEFINITELY
NOT PERFECT IT'S A COMPROMISE
AND A SOMEONE WHO REPRESENTS A
DISTRICT THAT AT ONE POINT HELD
ONE THIRD OF THE LEGAL LICENSES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- BUT
WE HAVE HAD A QUITE A NUMBER OF
EXPERIENCES- IN TERMS OF BOTH
THE SUCCESSES BUT IMPERFECTIONS
OF THE BALLOT INITIATIVE- WHEN
VOTERS PASSED PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR IN TWENTY SIXTEEN- EVERY
COUNTY TOOK A DIFFERENT PATH
AND WE HAVE FIFTY DIFFERENT
COUNTIES. SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
THAT I REPRESENTS WITHIN FIRST
THE FIRST FOUR MONTHS OF THE
LAW BEING PASSED. WAS ABLE TO
APPROVE EIGHT HUNDRED DIFFERENT
LICENSES IN THE FIRST FOUR
MONTHS- AND THAT IS HOW WE
ENDED UP BEING A COUNTY THAT
HAD SO MANY OF THE LICENSES.
AND ON THIS FLOOR IN THIS BODY
HAS TALKED SO MUCH ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE. OF ALLOWING FOR
SMALL GROWERS SMALL CULTIVATORS
AT TO HAVE A STAKE IN THE GAME-
TO ENSURE THAT THIS INDUSTRY IS
ONE THAT SUPPORTS ALSO. UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND THE
REALITY IS THAT FOUR YEARS
LATER. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE HAVE SEEN IN OUR DISTRICT
AND I THINK THAT THIS TRAILER
BILL ADDRESSES IT IT'S
SOMETHING- RELATED TO STACKED
LICENSES. BUT CONCEPT THAT MANY
BIG GROWERS HAVE MULTIPLE SMALL
LICENSES- IN ORDER TO GET NINE
HUNDRED ACRES A HUNDRED AND
SEVETY FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN ACRES NINETY ACRES BIG.
ACREAGE FOR THEM NOW THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE TO TRY TO PREVENT
THIS TRY TO ENSURE THAT WE
WOULD HAVE SOME OF THE SMALL
GROWERS BE COMPETITIVE IN THIS.
AND SO FOR THESE REASONS AT
THIS PARTICULAR TRAILER BILL AS
IT RELATES TO THE SMALL
LICENSES- AND IN THE STACKED
LICENSES SPECIFICALLY PUTS A
LIMIT ON THIS WE HAD FOR YEARS-
FOR FOLKS TO COMPLETE THE
PROCESS BOTH AT THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION. AND AT THE STATE
LEVEL AND THE COULD THE IDEA
WAS NEVER THAT BIG COMPANIES
WOULD SWEEP UP THE LITTLE ONES
IT WAS NEVER THAT IDEA BUT THE
REALITY AND THE DATA SHOW THAT
THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING- WHICH
COULD COMMUNITIES WHERE WE HAVE
BEEN VERY GENEROUS FOR WE HAVE
TRIED TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
IMPLEMENT THE LAW AND SO I WANT
TO POINT THAT OUT BECAUSE I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION AND I THINK THAT NOW
THIS BODY HAS A DIFFERENT
DILEMMA. THE DILEMMA OF NOT
JUST THINKING ABOUT HOW WE
MOVE. FROM THE UNLICENSED- E.
NO COMMUNITY TO GET THEM TO BE
LICENSE BUT ALSO HOW WE DO
RIGHT FOR ALL LOCAL COMMUNITIES
IN TERMS OF ENSURING THAT THE
IDEA BEHIND. THIS BALLOT
INITIATIVE TO ALLOW A
COMPETITIVE FIELD AMONG ALL
PRODUCERS GROWERS- THE- EASE IS
ACTIVE AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE SEEN SO I KNOW THAT
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION IN THIS BODY AND I
WANTED TO THE SPECIFICALLY
RAISES. BECAUSE THE ISSUES THAT
THAT HAPPENED IN ONE COUNTY ARE
NOT THE SAME- IN OTHER COUNTIES
SO WHEN WE'RE DEALING WITH
FIFTY EIGHT DIFFERENT COUNTIES-
WE HAVE SOME SERIOUS
DISCUSSIONS TO BE HAD. ABOUT
HOW WE ENSURE- THE BALANCE
BETWEEN THE COUNTIES THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO PROVE ANYTHING
BUT ALSO THE COUNTIES- WHO HAVE
BEEN EXCEPTIONALLY GENEROUS AND
ARE NOW SEEN THAT THE SPIRIT OF
THE VOTERS- IS IN JEOPARDY.
BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE FIGURED OUT
HOW TO GO AROUND SOME OF THE
PROCESS SEASON I WANT TO SAY
THAT AS IT RELATES TO SEEK
WELL. SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
DECIDED TO DO- A PROGRAMMATIC
ER BECAUSE IT'S FASTER
IT WOULDN'T BE THAT PLACE AND
EVEN WITH THOSE. ELEMENTS IN
PLACE OF TRYING TO HELP PEOPLE
GO THROUGH THE PROCESS FASTER
WE'VE HAD THESE CHALLENGES SO I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE TO SHARE
THAT WITH FOLKS- AND ENCOURAGED
AS DISCUSSIONS MOVE FORWARD. WE
TRY TO FIND A WAY TO ENSURE
THAT ALL KEY FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES- WE DEAL WITH IT I
THINK THE UNINTENDED
REPERCUSSIONS. OF THE BALLOT
INITIATIVE. FOR FIFTY DIFFERENT
COUNTIES WHICH I KNOW IS VERY
DIFFICULT SO- WITH THAT TIME I
WILL BE SUPPORTING AT THIS.
PARTICULAR TRAILER BILL AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS. SENATOR DOLLY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SO WE HAD LINK THE
DEBATE ON THIS BILL YESTERDAY.
AND I JUST WANT TO REFLECT ON
SOME OF THE COMMENTS FROM MY
FROM THE LAST SPEAKER I'M THE
ONLY FARMER I BELIEVE LIKE. ON
THIS FLOOR. TEN WE ABIDE BY ALL
LOT OF A LOT OF DIFFERENT RULES
BUT W HAD A PROPOSITION THAT
PUT US IN THIS SITUATION. AND
WE TALKED ABOUT THAT YESTERDAY
BUT- INTEL WE THE PERSONAL I
THINK I'M GONNA LAY OUT THIS
BILL AGAIN BECAUSE IT'S NOT
COOKING WE'RE GOING TO PUSH IT
THROUGH AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GET WHAT WE WANT. I DIDN'T
WISER HURRY WISER HURRY NOT TO
SLOW DOWN AND REALLY TALK ABOUT
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
HERE I THINK WE SHOULD SLOW
DOWN AND WE SHOULD DO THIS TRY
TO DO THIS RIGHT IS NOT GOING
TO BE PERFECT. ANYWAY I HAVE.
TWO DAYS AGO WE HAD A FIRE THE
LAB ARE YOU PROBABLY ALL KNOW
IN SISKIYOU COUNTY. BERNIE INTO
ILLEGAL. POT GROWS IN. THERE
WAS A SHOOT OUT. N. ONE PERSON
DIED. SO IN AWE AND ARE
COUNTIES WE HAVE ONE CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER FOR
COUNTIES THAT ARE FORTY FIVE
HUNDRED SQUARE MILES YOU CAN'T
POSSIBLY DEAL WITH THE ILLEGAL
GROWS THAT ARE HAPPENING SO
THEY'RE COMPETING AGAINST THOSE
LEGAL GROWS. THAT YOU HAVE IN
YOUR AREA SEMI TALK ABOUT SMALL
FARMERS VERSUS BIG FARMERS LOOK
THIS IS CALIFORNIA YOU BETTER
GROWTH YOU'RE GOING TO BE A
FARMER YOU'RE NOT GONNA STAY IN
BUSINESS BECAUSE OF ALL THE
REGULATORY LAWS THAT ARE
PASSED. IN THIS BODY SO FOR ME
I WANT TO SAY WE NEED TO NUMBER
ONE. WE NEED TO WORK ON. GOING
AFTER THE LEGAL GROWS BECAUSE
IF YOU HAVE IF YOU DON'T
ENFORCE ILLEGAL GROWS YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO GET THE GUY THAT'S
TRYING TO BE LEGAL WHO'S PAYING
THE MONEY. AND GOING TO THE
REGULATORY PROCESS THAT WE SET
UP. HE CAN'T COMPETE WITH THE
ILLEGAL PRODUCT THAT'S COMING
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA SO. I'M
GONNA LAY OFF AYE I SUGGEST
THAT WE WAIT THERE'S NO REASON
TO HURRY ON THIS WE NEED TO.
SPEND SOME MORE TIME AND DO IT
RIGHT IS WHAT I SAID. IN THE
THERE ARE BUDGET HEARING. LET'S
TAKE OUR TIME THE DEVIL'S IN
THE DETAILS AND LOOK YES T'S
PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE OF PROP
SIXTY FOUR IS NOT EASY AND
YOU'RE RIGHT. EVERY COUNTY DOES
SOMETHING DIFFERENT. BUT UTIL
WE FOR STILL HELP COUNTIES TO
ENFORCE ILLEGAL GROWS WE'RE
NEVER GONNA GET THERE AND THESE
LEGAL PEOPLE ARE GOING TO GIVE
UP. THE CENTER FROM THE NORTH
COAST BROUGHT UP SOME REALLY
GREAT POINTS AND TRUST ME.
THEY'VE BEEN GROWING MARIJUANA
IN HUMBOLDT COUNTY. FOR I WAS
BORN BUT I'M FIFTY FIVE THEY'VE
BEEN DOING IT THERE AND THEY'RE
TRYING TO BECOME LEGAL AND DO
IT IN A REGULATED MARKET INTEL
WE SLOW DOWN AND DO IT RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA END UP WITH THE
SAME EXACT THING AND WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GET WHAT WE ASK FOR SO
I ASK THAT WE STILL. DO NOT
PASS THIS BILL AND GIVE US SOME
TIME TO DO IT RIGHT. SENATOR
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT PRESIDENT I TO RISE
WITH GREAT CONCERNS ON THIS
MEASURE- A MEASURE THAT HAS
BEEN CLEARLY DEBATED AND I
COMMEND OUR BUDGET YEAR FALL OR
WORK THE BUDGET COMMITTEE BOTH
HOUSES- BUT I STILL THINK
THERE'S GREAT CONCERN SPECIALLY
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE EQUITY
ASPECT OF THIS MEASURE WHY IS
IT THAT EVERY EQUITY APPLICANT
HAS A PROVISIONAL LICENSE WHAT
WE WANT TO CUT THE TIME FRAME
OF THOSE EQUITY AYE A LICENSE
YES. YOU'VE EXPANDED FOUR YEAR
BUT AGAIN. BUT IT'S VERY LITTLE
CONFIDENCE BECAUSE WE DO THE
SAME THING TIME AND TIME AGAIN
OF PROMISES PROMISES. DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING STATED MARCH I
WATCHED IN AMERICA'S CONTINUE
TO RIDE A PROMISSORY NOTE. TO
THE NEGRO THAT KEEPS COMING
BACK AND SUFFICIENT FUNDS FOR
WE ARE FIFTY SEVEN YEARS LATER
AND WE'RE STILL GETTING
PROMISSORY NOTES. AND COMING
BACK WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
WE HAVE SPENT MORE MONEY ON
ENFORCEMENT THEN WE TRULY
SPENT. ON HELPING THESE EQUITY
APPLICANTS WE SHOULD ALL BE
CONCERNED THAT 80% OF ALL
LICENSES IN THE SPACE INDUSTRY
AND A HALF YEARS A CONTROLLED
BY WHITE MEN. YEAH MINORITIES
WOMEN DISABLED VETERANS
STRUGGLE EVERY DAY BANNER THIS
SPACE LEGALLY. AND WE'VE SPENT
MORE AGAIN MORE MONEY ON
ENFORCEMENT AND YOU CONTINUE TO
CALL IT THE BLACK MARKET BUT
IT'S NOT BLACK AND BROWN PEOPLE
IN THIS MARKET THEY'RE NOT THE
ILLEGAL GROWERS AND THEN YOU
WANT TO CONTINUE TO WEAPONIZE
SEQUEL. ON PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING TO ENTER THE SPACE THIS
IS WHAT PEOPLE ARE LEAVING
CALIFORNIA. THE L. R. WHY
SHOULD YOU BE TAPPED OUT A
SEQUEL EXEMPTS I MEAN ARE.
ALTERCATION JUST OPEN UP A
DISPENSER MOTHER'S BUSINESS
AFTAB SECRET APPROVAL TO OPEN
UP A STORE MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO
SENSE SO. I HAVE GREAT CONCERNS
AND I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A GREAT
NEGOTIATIONS AND COMMITMENTS
MADE BUT AGAIN I LIVE LONG
ENOUGH TO KNOW PROMISES ARE NOT
REALITIES. SENATOR BATES. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- I THINK I
REMINDED MYSELF AND CERTAINLY
MANY OF US OFTEN THAT WHEN
GOVERNMENT MAKES PROMISES THAT
NEEDS TO KEEP THEM OR WE LOSE
THE CONFIDENCE IN OUR
GOVERNMENTS AND I THINK WE'VE
SEEN A LOT OF THAT IN THE PAST
YEAR AND A HALF THE VOTERS WERE
TOLD WHEN WE CREATED A
LEGALIZED MARKET PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA WE ARE GONNA SHUT
DOWN THE ILLEGAL MARKET PLACE.
WE NEED AN OVERWHELMING SHOW OF
FORCE BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BY OUR GOVERNMENT TO
ENSURE THAT THAT PROMISE IS
KEPT TO THE PUBLIC THAT SHOW
FOR SHOULD BE IN THE FORM OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
ENFORCEMENT WE SHOULD BE
PROTECTING THE LEGAL MARKET
PLACE WE SHOULD BE PROTECTING.
VERY IMPORTANTLY ONE OF THE
LARGEST GROUPS IN CALIFORNIA
THAT HAVE INFLUENCE IN OUR
LIVES THIS LEGISLATURE IS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY. WE
SHOULD BE DEALING WITH THE
ILLEGAL WATER DIVERSIONS THAT
ARE WORSENING THE IMPACTS OF
OUR DROUGHT WE SHOULD BE
PROTECTING PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
LANDS FROM ENVIRONMENTAL
DEGRADATION. WE SHOULD BE
ELIMINATING THE ILLEGAL GROW
SITES REDUCE THE RISK OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES AND WE
SHOULD BE PROTECTING OUR
WILDLIFE BIRDS MOUNTAIN LIONS
THAT ARE AT RISK DUE TO THE
ILLEGAL USE OF PESTICIDES AND
RODENTICIDES. WE JUST SEEM TO
TRY TO OUTLAW OF THOSE
PARTICULAR- TESTIFIED THAT ARE
NEEDED AND CAN BE APPROPRIATELY
USE RATHER THAN GOING AFTER THE
BAD ACTORS FOR USING THEM THERE
USING THEM ILLEGALLY AND
HARMING OUR WILDLIFE. TRULY
DEALING WITH THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY MEANS DEALING WITH
THOSE ISSUES IT MEANS
INCREASING CRIMINAL PENALTIES
IT MEANS PUTTING ILLEGAL GROW
SITE OPERATORS IN PRISON IT
MEANS MOST IMPORTANTLY AS WE'VE
HEARD FROM OUR- GOOD SENATOR
FROM BEAVER WHO ARE THEY HAVE
TO. LIVE ALONG SIDE OF MUCH OF
THE F. GIVE US RESOURCES
RESOURCES FOR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT ARE ABSOLUTELY
MANDATORY IF WE ARE GOING TO
MEET THE PROMISES WE MADE TO
THE PUBLIC IT REQUIRES AN
ACTION PLAN AND IT REQUIRES
ACTION FROM THE GOVERNOR'S
ADMINISTRATION. AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE TIME
IS NOW THE JOB NEEDS TO GET
DONE IN THIS BILL DOESN'T GET
US THERE. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR SKINNER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CONCLUDE YES. THANK YOU. AS
I REFERENCE THIS BILL WILL BE
AMENDED AND I REFERENCE SOME OF
THE AMENDMENTS AND ONE OF THE
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS IS THAT.
IT WILL CLARIFY. OR RATHER IT
WILL YES WILL CLARIFY THAT THE
HUNDRED MILLION. IN CANNABIS
LOCAL JURISDICTION GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH WAS ADOPTED THE
BUDGET BILL WOULD BE DEPLOYED
QUICKLY SO THAT IT CAN HELP
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MEET THE
DEADLINES IN THE BILL WHEN I
MENTION SOME OTHER THINGS IN
THESE DISCUSSIONS ARE UNDER
WAY. THE NECESSITY OF THE
TIMING TODAY TO ACT ON THE BILL
EVEN THOUGH WE KNOW THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE ADDING ADDITIONAL
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL IS
BECAUSE OUR BUDGET BILL.
CREATED THE CONSOLIDATION OF
THE DEPARTMENTS INTO THE ONE
OFFICE OF DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL SO THAT IS WHY
WE NEED TO ACT TODAY WHAT IS
BEFORE US BUT WE WILL. SOON ACT
ON THE ADDITIONAL THINGS I
MENTIONED IN THE OTHER
DISCUSSIONS THAT ARE UNDER WAY
WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. INTEGRITY VERY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES NO
BACKER HI PORGES NO BRADFORD.
CABALLERO CORTESE FIVE DALLY.
GOD HI THERE ARE SO HI EGGMAN
HI GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
HI FURTADO. NO JONES. KAMLAGER
BLARED HI LEYVA HI LIMóN HI
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ. MAN FIVE
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. A SHOW OF
BOTH. PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH AYE RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. HI
STERN HI I'M BURKE HI WHITE
HOUSE SKI HI WIENER AYE WILK NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BRADFORD I. CABALLERO DALLY.
GROVE NO. JONES KAMLAGER.
MELENDEZ NIELSEN PHOTOBOOK. I
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS FIVE IN THE
BUDGET BILL IS APPROVED WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY NINE PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY THREE
BUT ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
COURTS IN MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. CENTER SKINNER
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS. AB ONE
FORTY THREE MAKES THE STATUTORY
CHANGES TO IMPLEMENT THE COURTS
PORTIONS OF OUR BUDGET ACT. IT
EXPANDS THE STATEWIDE PILOT
PROGRAM. APPROVED IN THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT. FOR ONLINE
TRAFFIC. ADJUDICATION AND
ABILITY TO PAY PROJECTS. IT
REDUCES FINES AND FEES FOR
ELIGIBLE PARTICIPANTS FOR
TRAFFIC AND NON TRAFFIC
INFRACTIONS. AND IT IS THIS IS
PART OF THE BUDGET FINANCING
FEES RELIEF PACKAGE FROM THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
THAT WAS INCLUDED ON OUR BUDGET
BILL. I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUED BUDGET
CONVERSATIONS. AND WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE COURTS
ON THE CIVIL ASSESSMENT HELLO-
ELIMINATION THAT WE- DIDN'T WE
PROVIDED THE FUNDS FOR BUT IT'S
NOT YET CONTAINED IN THE BILL
BUT THOSE DISCUSSIONS ARE
UNDERWAY AND IN THE MEANTIME I
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
BILL. BETTER DRESS OF. YOUR
MANAGER UP I I'M GLAD THAT WE
CAME TO AGREEMENT ON THE TERMS
ALL ITEMS IN THIS TRAILER BILL
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY MORE WORK TO
BE DONE THE BUDGET DOES NOT
INCLUDE ADDED AND NEEDED
FUNDING FOR COURT REPORTERS AND
INTERPRETERS I UNDERSTAND OUR
TASK IS TO SUPPORT FURTHER
EFFICIENCIES AND MODERNIZING
OUR CHORDS BUT WE MUST PRESERVE
AND ENHANCE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE THE HARDEST
TIME USING OUR COURTS. WE ALL
KNOW THE COURT GOING TO COURT
IS NEVER EASY AND OFTEN THERE
IS DEEP TRAUMA IN THOSE HALLS
AND COURTROOMS WE NEED TO
PRESERVE PEOPLE'S HUMANITY AND
OUR VALUES WELL IMPLEMENTING
EFFICIENCIES THAT WORKS FOR
EVERYONE WHAT WE SEEK
MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO JUSTICE
FOR USERS WE MUST BE RESPECTFUL
OF THE CALIFORNIANS WHO USE THE
CHORDS AND THEIR VARIOUS NEEDS
THOSE IN NEED OF LANGUAGE
SERVICES INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES. ARE DIVERSE
POPULATION IS A DIVERSE AND WE
MUST RESPECT THAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE HI SINGMAN
CENTER SKINNER YOU MAY CONCLUDE.
THANK YOU I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES HI BACKER AYE BORJAS AYE
BRADFORD HI CUT BY ADAM HI
COURTESY HI DALLY I DODD HI
DURAZO. HI EGGMAN I GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HI HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO HI HER TADO AYE JONES
ARE HIGH KAMLAGER HI LAYERED.
HI LEYVA HI LIMóN HI MCGUIRE.
FIVE MELENDEZ FIVE MEN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF
BOTH. HI PAM HI PORTANTINO HI
ROTH FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER AYE
STERN HI I'M BURKE. HI MY
CASKEY HI WIENER HI WILK HI
HIGHS FORTY KNOWS ZERO THE
BUDGET BILL IS APPROVED ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY SENATOR CENTERS
CAN YOU SKINNER IS READY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY
FIVE BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC SAFETY AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. YOU MAY THANK
YOU MAY THINK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SO AB ONE FORTY FIVE
IS THE TRAILER BILL REGARD
RELATING TO PUBLIC SAFETY. AND
NOTABLY IT INCLUDES THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEISLATURE'S
DATA AND EVIDENCE BASED
PROPOSALS FOR A VARIETY OF-
ACTIONS INCLUDE THAT WOULD
PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY AND
REMOVE BARRIERS TO SUCCESSFUL
REENTRY. AND ACHIEVING LONG
TERM BUDGETARY SAVINGS IT'S
MAKES- STATUTE AUTHORIZING THE
ESTABLISHMENT AND OPERATION OF
THE DEUEL VOCATIONAL
INSTITUTION. IN OPERATIVE SO IT
MAKES THE STATUTE THAT
AUTHORIZES THAT IN OPERATIVE ON
OCTOBER FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AS A RESULT OF THIS PRISON'S
CLOSURE. REESE'S THE OVERSIGHT
OF LOCAL DETENTION FACILITIES
THOSE ARE JAILS BY ALLOWING
AUTHORIZED. PERSONNEL FROM THE
BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS TO ENTER THE
FACILITY FOR UNANNOUNCED
INSPECTIONS. AND IT EXPANDS THE
NUMBER OF COMMISSIONERS BONTA
BRO OR BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS
ALONG WITH SOME PROVISIONS
RELATED. TO DIVERSITY AND
EXPERIENCE FOR THOSE
COMMISSIONERS AND WITHOUT AYE
ASPIRATE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SINGMAN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES NO
BECKER HI FORTUS NO BRADFORD HI
BY ADAM HI CORTESE AYE DALLY.
NO DODD HI TORONTO HI EGGMAN HI
GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG HI HUESO HI HER TADO
NO JONES. KAMLAGER I LAYERED HI
LEYVA HI LIMóN HI MCGUIRE. HI
MELENDEZ NO MAN HI NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH NO
HAN. HI PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI STERN HI
I'M BURKE HI WHITE HOUSE SKI HI
WIENER AYE WILK NO. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS.
JONES NOW. PRICE TWENTY NINE
KNOWS TEN ABOUT YOUR BILL IS
APPROVED MEMBERS ARE GONNA MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER THIRTY ONE.
SENATOR SKINNER IS PREPARED
PLEASE REACH. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
FORTY NINE BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AN ACT
RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET SENT CENTER SKINNER THE
FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SO MEMBERS NOW WE
HAVE EIGHTY ONE FORTY NINE THE
TRAILER BILL FOR
TRANSPORTATION. AND THIS IS
WHAT IT DOES IS IT EXTENDS AND
EXPANDS THE STATUTORY RELIEF
THAT WE PROVIDED TO OUR TRANSIT
OPERATORS. IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET TO HELP THEM RECOVER
FROM THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
AND ALL OF US KNOW. HOW MUCH
THE FARE BOX THE FAIR INCOME
DROPPED WITH THE UNDER THE
PANDEMIC WITH SO MANY PEOPLE
WHO NO LONGER THAN BY. ROAD
TRANSIT AND THE HELP THAT THEY
NEED. IT EXTENDS THE STATE'S
DELEGATION AUTHORITY UNDER THE
NATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION ACT THROUGH JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. IT
PROVIDES FOR THE CREATION IN
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE CLEAN
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM. WHICH WILL
ALLOCATE A BILLION DOLLARS OVER
THE NEXT THREE YEARS TO HELP
CLEAN UP OUR ROADWAYS AND
HIGHWAYS. IT PROVIDES STATUTORY
FLEXIBILITY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IN MEETING THEIR
REQUIRED SPENDING LEVELS ON
ROAD MAINTENANCE- AND WE KNOW
THAT MANY THINGS WERE
DISRUPTED. DURING THE PANDEMIC
SO WE ARE GIVING THIS EXTENDED
TIME PERIOD SO THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE WITH GOOD ROAD
MAINTENANCE. AND PROVIDES FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF A LIMITED
PILOT PROGRAM. TO PRODUCE
DIGITAL DRIVER'S LICENSE IN
STATE ID'S. WITH THE DMV AND
THERE IS VERY STRONG PRIVACY
AND DATA SECURITY REQUIREMENTS
IN THAT PROVISION AND WITH THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SENATOR TROUBLED. SEVEN MINUTES
ON THE SPELL AT THE DESK THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ THE AMENDMENTS
AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR OCHO OF
FOLK THAT ONE. SENATOR BOTH THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. CALIFORNIANS
ARE CURRENTLY IN DURING THE
HIGHEST GAS PRICES IN THE
NATION AVERAGING FOUR DOLLARS
AND TWENTY TWO CENTS FOR
REGULAR GALLON OF GASOLINE
WHICH IS MORE THAN A DOLLAR
ABOVE THE NATIONAL AVERAGE. THE
ADVERSE IMPACTS OF HIGH GAS
PRICES AND TAXES THAT WE KNOW
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTS OUR
LOW TO MIDDLE INCOME RESIDENTS
NOT ONLY AFFECTS DRIVERS. IT
INCREASES THE COST OF LIVING.
INCLUDING BUSINESS COST AND
FOOD PRICES HAMPERING OUR
RELIEF EFFORTS AND ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. TODAY JULY FIRST
CALIFORNIA'S EXCISE TAX ON A
GALLON OF GASOLINE WILL RISE TO
FIFTY ONE POINT ONE SENSE. AT A
TIME WHEN THE STATE BUDGET IS
ENJOYING A HISTORIC SURPLUS
CALIFORNIANS DESERVE A TAX
BREAK NOT HIGHER TAXES. THE
AVERAGE FAMILY OF FOUR PAYS AS
MUCH AS EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS
IN GAS TAXES A YEAR AND THIS
INCREASE IS GOING TO COST
CALIFORNIA DRIVERS AN
ADDITIONAL EIGHTY THREE
MILLION. DOLLARS IN THE NEXT
YEAR ALONE. GAS COSTS ACCOUNT
414% OF EXPENDITURES IN THE
AGRICULTURAL SECTOR AND RAISING
THE GAS TAX WOULD INHERENTLY
RAISE THE PRICE OF FOOD.
FURTHER RESULT IN NOT JUST A
HIGHER TAXES THE PUMP BUT ALSO
INCREASE COSTS AT THE CHECK OUT
LINE. I GAS TAX HOLIDAY OR MORE
SPECIFICALLY A FULL MORATORIUM
ON CALIFORNIA'S GASOLINE EXCISE
TAX BACKFIELD WITH GENERAL
FUND. DOLLARS FROM THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO
FISCAL YEAR WOULD PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED RELIEF FOR CALIFORNIANS.
FOUR YEARS THIS LEGISLATURE HAS
FAILED TO PRIORITIZE
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS IN
ITS GENERAL FUND SPENDING
RELYING ON BOND FUNDING FOR
INCREASING TAXES. IT IS TIME TO
GIVE CALIFORNIA'S A BREAK FROM
CALIFORNIA'S HIGH COST OF
LIVING THAT INCLUDES THE
STATE'S HIGH TECH HIGH TAXES
AND GAS PRICES. PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS CRITICAL MOMENT FOR
WORKING FAMILIES AND I ASK THAT
YOU DO NOT PLACE THEM ON THE
TABLE. THANK YOU. SENATOR
HERTZBERG FOR WHAT PURPOSE YOU
RISE THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I'M A MOVE TO LEAD HIM TO THE
TABLE. ENTER HERTZBERG HAS.
MADE A MOTION TO LAY THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE IT IS
NOT DEBATABLE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES.
NO BAKER HI PORGES NO BRADFORD
HI CUT BY ADAM I CORTESE HI
DALLY. NO DODD HI DURAZO HI
EGGMAN HI GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI
GROSS. NO HERTZBERG HI HUESO.
HI HER TADO HI JONES NO
KAMLAGER HI LAYERED HI LEYVA HI
LIMóN HI MCGUIRE. HI MELENDEZ
NO MAN HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO
A SHOW OF THE OAK. NO HAN. HI
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER. HI STERN HI I'M BURKE
HI MY CASTING FIVE WIENER HI
WILK NOW. I THIRTY ONE KNOWS
NINE. THE AMENDMENTS ARE LAID
ON THE TABLE MEMBERS ARE GOING
TO GO BACK TO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE BILL IN CHIEF IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE BILL IN CHIEF. SEEING NO
FURTHER DISCUSSION CENTER
SKINNER YOU MAY CONCLUDE. THANK
YOU I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THAT MAKE THEM. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES
HI BAKER FIVE BORJAS HI
BRADFORD I CUT BY ADAM HI
CORTESE HI DOLLY HI DODD. HI
THERE ASA I EGGMAN HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH I HERTZBERG
HI HUESO. HI HER TADO. JONES HI
KAMLAGER HI FLARED I LEYVA FIVE
LIMóN HI MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ.
IN HI NEWMAN HI NIELSEN BY A
SHOW OF VOGUE HI PAN. HI
PORTANTINO HI ROTH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER HI STERN I AM BURKE HI
BY CAL SKI HI WIENER. I WILK HI
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
HER TADO. MELENDEZ HI. I THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE BUDGET BILL IS
APPROVED LIVING ON ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY TWO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
FIFTY BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET CENTER SKINNER
THE FOR TWO YEARS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB ONE
FIFTY IS OUR TRAILER BILL ON
TAXATION AND REVENUE AND IT
DOES A NUMBER OF THINGS
INCLUDING- CREATESHIRING
CREDITS FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
AND FOR BUSINESSES THAT HIRE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE HOMELESS.
IT EXPANDS OUR CALIFORNIA
COMPETES TAX CREDIT WHICH IN.
CENTER BAEZ'S BUSINESSES TO
MAKE INVESTMENTS. IN AND CREATE
JOBS IN CALIFORNIA. IT EXTENDS
THE TAX CREDIT FOR THE%
REHABILITATION OF HISTORIC
BUILDINGS THAT EXTENDS THE TAX
CREDIT FOR THE DONATION OF
FRESH FRUITS AND VEGETABLES TO
OUR FOOD BANKS THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT TAX CREDIT TOWARD
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY. AND
SOMETHING THAT AS VICE CHAIR OF
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS I'M
PARTICULARLY PROUD OF IT
PERMANENTLY. PUTS IN OUR BUDGET
THE EXEMPTION FOR SALES TAX ON
DIAPERS AND MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS.
IT ALSO- TO THE ELECTIVE TAX
FOR PASS THROUGH ENTITIES TO
HELP OFFSET THE CAP ON THE SALT
DEDUCTION AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
WHICH WE ALL KNOW WAS SET AT-
THE GENOME TO BLOW THAT NUMBER.
WAS A HUNDRED WELL TEN
THOUSAND. THANK YOU A SINNER
FROM SANTA CRUZ FOR HELP ME
REMIND ME NO I THINK IT YOU ARE
CORRECT WAS TWO THOUSAND. AND
IT CONTAINS A VARIETY OF TAX
INCENTIVES TO ENCOURAGE HIRING
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN
CALIFORNIA THAT SUPPORTS SMALL
BUSINESSES FOOD BANKS AN
INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYERS AND WITH
THAT LAST YEAR I VOTE. SENATOR
BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I HAVE AMENDMENTS AT
THE DESK MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ AMENDMENTS BY SENATOR
BATES SAT ONE. CENTER BATES THE
FLOOR'S YOURS MEMBERS ON MONDAY
I LEARNED THAT THE BUDGET DID
NOT INCLUDE THE RESTORATION OF
THE NET OPERATING LOSS
DEDUCTION THAT WAS SUSPENDED IN
CAPS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET SO MY AMENDMENTS TODAY
WOULD LIFT THE SUSPENSION OF
THE NET OPERATING LOSS
DEDUCTION IN IN THE CAP ON
BUSINESS INCENTIVE TAX CREDITS
SUCH AS THE R&D CREDIT THAT
WERE IMPOSED TO ADDRESS A
BUDGET FOR FOOTBALL THAT NEVER
MATERIALIZED. MANY COMMENTS
WERE MADE ON MONDAY PRAISING
THE BUDGET ETHNOLOGY INK THAT
MEMBERS PRIORITIES WERE MET AND
EVEN EXCEEDED AND MANY OF THE
COMMENTS THANKFULLY I WAS THE A
KNOWLEDGE MENT OF THE HARD WORK
OF OUR BUDGET CHAIR AND ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS BOB IT ALSO
THAT WE WILL HAVE TO WORK HARD
TO SUSTAIN THIS BUDGET. WELL
ONE OF THE THINGS WE MUST DO TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR ECONOMY
CONTINUES TO GROW AND GET
STRONGER AS WE RECOVER WE CAN
ONLY DO IT IF WE CONTINUE TO
INVEST IN AND PROMOTE
CALIFORNIA'S INNOVATORS
INNOVATORS LIKE THOSE IN THE
LIFE SCIENCE INDUSTRY WHO MADE
COVERT NINETEEN VACCINE
POSSIBLE INNOVATORS LIKE THE
GREEN TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY THAT
ARE GOING TO BUILD THE CARBON
REDUCE WORLD THAT WE ALL WANT
WE NEED TO ENCOURAGE THE
INNOVATORS AND ARE STRUGGLING
SMALL BUSINESSES NOW. NOT IN
SEVERAL YEARS ON THE TWENTY
TWENTY BUDGETS CARRY THAT
PROVISIONS ARE EFFECTIVE WE ARE
PROVIDING BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO SCHOOLS RENTERS THE
UNEMPLOYED ALL OF WHICH IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BUT BY NOT
RESTORING THE NET OPERATING
LOSS ANOTHER BUSINESS TAX
CREDITS WE ARE CAUSING EVEN
GREATER FINANCIAL STRAIN FOR
EMPLOYERS WHO HAVE SUFFERED
STAGGERING LOSSES OVER THE PAST
YEAR AND ON WHOM WE RELY FOR
THE RESOURCES THAT WE NEED TO.
OUR CERTAINLY MEET THE
PRIORITIES THAT ARE CONTAINED
IN THIS BUDGET WE NEED THEM TO
CREATE THE JOBS TO GET OUR
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK THE
BIPARTISAN COLLECTION OF
SENATORS HAVE CO AUTHORED
LEGISLATION TO RESTORE- THE IN
A WELL DEDUCTION AND RESTORE
THE R&D TAX CREDITS JUST AS A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF SIGNED ONTO
LETTERS CALLING FOR SIMILAR
ACTIONS NOW IS THE TIME TO TAKE
ACTION TO ACHIEVE WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN ASKING FOR. I KNOW THE
SENATE FROM ANGELES WILL ASK
THAT YOU LAY MY AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE. THAT MEMBERS WITH AN
AYE VOTE ON THAT MOTION YOU
WILL BE SAYING NO TO
INNOVATION. YOU WILL BE SAYING
NO TO JOB CREATION. YOU WILL BE
SAYING NO TO ALL OF YOUR
PRIORITIES IN THE FUTURE. HE
WILL BE TELLING OUR INNOVATORS
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T WANT JOB
CREATION. BE BOLD IMPROVE MY
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU. SENATOR
HERTZBERG THINK ABOUT A
PRESIDENT A MOVE TO LAY THE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE.
SENATOR HERTZBERG MOVED TO LAND
THE TO PLACE THAT AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE HE ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU AND- THIS
CENTER BATES US FOR NO VOTE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
NO BACKER FIVE FORTUS. BRADFORD
HI CUT BY ADAM HI CORTESE HI
DALLY NO DODD. I DRAWS. HI
EGGMAN HI GLAZER HI GONZALEZ HI
GROVE NO HERTZBERG HI HUESO HI
HER TADO. HI JONES NO KAMLAGER.
HI LAYARD HI LEYVA. HI LIMóN.
HI MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ NO MAN
HI NEWMAN. NIELSEN NO A CHIRLA
BOTH NO PAN HI PORTANTINO HI
ROTH FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
STERN. AMBERG HI WHY CASTING HI
WIENER HI WILK NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. PORGES.
NEWMAN STERN. HI. NEWMAN. I
THIRTY KNOWS NINE THE
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN LAID ON
THE TABLE MEMBERS ARE GOING TO
RETURN TO OUR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE BILL IN CHIEF
SENATOR DR SO. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I RISE TO SHARE MY PRIDE
IN MY EXCITEMENT. FOR THE
INCLUSION. OF A FUNDS IN THIS
BUDGET TO ESTABLISH ONE OF THE
NATION'S FIRST HOMELESS HIRING
TAX CREDITS. MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND I HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS SINCE BEFORE
THE INSTABILITY OF THE
PANDEMIC. THE HOMELESS HIRING
TAX CREDIT WILL HELP CREATE
MEANINGFUL EMPLOYMENT FOR
APPROXIMATELY THREE THOUSAND
MEN AND WOMEN WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED HOMELESSNESS BUT WE
HAVE WORK HISTORIES AND SKILLS
THAT WILL BENEFIT OUR ECONOMY
THEY WANT TO GET BACK ON THEIR
FEET THEY NEED THAT
OPPORTUNITY. I AM SO PROUD OF
PARTNERING WITH BUSINESS AND
COMMUNITY AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS THIS FUNDING
REFLECTS OUR STRAIGHT A STRONG
OUR STATE'S STRONG COMMITMENT
TO FOSTERING A STRONGER
WORKFORCE AND ACCESS TO GOOD
PAYING JOBS THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS. ITEM SENATE HUESO. THANK
YOU MEANT PRESIDENT I ALSO
WANTED THAT ON JUST TO COMMENT
I WAS WORKING ON A BILL OF FOUR
YEARS AGO TO- PROVIDE A TAX
CREDIT FOR YOUNG PEOPLE COMING
OUT OF A PRISON. AND ALTHOUGH
THIS THIS MATTER DOES NOT.
PRECISELY DO THAT I THINK IT'S
GOING TO COVER- OF A WIDE RANGE
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE HAVING A
HARD TIME WHEN OUR ECONOMY SO.
I WANNA. I WANT TO THANK THE
BUDGET WORKING GROUP AND
EVERYONE THAT WORK TOGETHER TO
ADD THIS. ELEMENT TO THIS
BUDGET IT'S SO IT'S A WONDERFUL
PIECE OF. OF A LARGE WONDERFUL
PROGRAM I THINK IT'S GOING TO
CHANGE LIVES AND HOPEFULLY- OUR
BUSINESS COMMUNITY PARTICIPATE
IN THIS IN THIS PROGRAM TO
HELP. LIFT PEOPLE OUT OF
POVERTY TAKE HIM OUT OF THE
STREETS AND INTO A HOME. THIS
IS A WONDERFUL WONDERFUL UP
PROGRAM AND I'M VERY EXCITED
SUPPORT THIS BUDGET. SENATE
BRADFORD. I TO JUST WANTED TO
VOICE MY SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE SPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF
WHAT HAPPENED TO SMALL
BUSINESSES DURING THE KING AND
DEMOCRATS AND ALONE FOR THE
EXTENSION OF THE ONE THOUSAND
DOLLAR TAX CREDIT FOR EVERY NEW
HIRE WE ARE TO COMMONSENSE
MEASURE AND I'M GLAD WITH THIS
COMMANDED UPON IT AND I THINK
IT'S GOING TO HELP THOSE KEEP
OUR BUSINESSES THAT WERE
IMPACTED GREATLY AND AS STATED-
THE HOMES SUCH CREDITORS TO FOR
HIRING HOMELESS PEOPLE SO. I
COMMEND AUTHOR. THIS MEASURE
SAID. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SANDERS CAN YOU MAKE
INCLUDE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
FIVE ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE
BATES. BAKER HI FOR JUST HI
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI
CORTESE FIVE DALLY HI DODD HI
TORONTO HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO. HI HER TADO FIVE
JONES HI KAMLAGER I LAYERED. HI
LEYVA HI LIMóN HI MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ HI MAN AYE NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
PAN HI PORTANTINO HI ROTH AYE
RUBIO. HI SKINNER AYE STERN HI
AMBERG. HI WHITE HOUSE SKI HI
WIENER HI WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES HI.
HIS BUYS FORTY NO ZERO THE
BUDGET BILL IS APPROVED MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
YEAH ASSEMBLY BILL ONE THIRTY
SIX BY THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET AN ACT RELATING TO
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE PROTECTED
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL
RELATED TO THE BUDGET. CENTER
SKINNER THE FOR YEARS. THANK
YOU AND MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS.
AB ONE THIRTY SIX IS THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES BUDGET
TRAILER BILL. AND I'M
PARTICULARLY- PROUD THAT WE ARE
TAKING THIS ACTION. THERE ARE
STILL SOME OF US ON THIS FLOOR
THAT SERVED IN THE LEGISLATURE
DURING THE RECESSION AND HAD TO
MAKE CUTS TO THE RATES THAT
WERE PAID OUR PROVIDERS ARE
DEEP PROVIDERS AND THOSE- CUTS
HAVE NOT YET FULLY BEEN
RESTORED EVEN OVER MANY YEARS
PAST THAT RECESSION. SO MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS PROVIDES FOR THE
SERVICE PROVIDER RATE REFORM
WITH IN THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES SYSTEM BY PROVIDING
PHASED IN RATE INCREASES OVER
FIVE YEARS AND SHIFTS THE
SYSTEM TO FOCUS ON CONSUMER
OUTCOMES IN A PERSON CENTRED
MODEL. AND I AM HOPEFUL THAT WE
ARE GOING TO BE ABLE TO MOVE UP
THAT TIMELINE THAT FIVE YEAR
TIMELINE TO A SHORTER TIMELINE-
IN THE FUTURE IF WE SEE
CONTINUED GOOD REVENUES IT ALSO
IMPLEMENTS A LANGUAGE ACCESS
AND CULTURAL COMPETENCY
INITIATIVES WITHIN OUR
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT. TO ESTABLISH A
PROGRAM TO INCREASE PATHWAYS TO
EMPLOYMENT FOR FOLKS WITH
DISABILITIES AND REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A TRAINING CURRICULUM
FOR DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS THAT PROMOTES
PERSON CENTERED SERVICES THAT
ARE CULTURALLY SENSITIVE. AND
WITHOUT AYE ELSEVIER AYE VOTE.
CENTER EGGMAN. I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST RISE AND
IN SUPPORT OF THIS THIS IS AN
AREA THAT WE DID A LOT OF WORK
IN AMMAN THANK TO THE BUDGET
STAFF AND EVERYBODY BUT HUGELY
IMPORTANT FOR OUR DE DE ID
COMMUNITIES WE HAVE LONG THIS
THIS COMMITTEE HAS LONG BEEN
NEGLECTED IN OUR WORK AND WE
WILL BE ABLE TO FIX SOME OF THE
RATES EXPAND THE SERVICES AND
REALLY TAKE IN THE INPUT THAT
WE HEARD FROM ADVOCATES AND
FAMILIES THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS A REALLY BE ABLE TO DO-
FULFILL THE OBLIGATIONS I THINK
WE HAVE AS CALIFORNIANS TO
THIS. VITAL PART OF OUR
COMMUNITY. SENATOR THERE'D.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT YOU
KNOW IT WHEN I WAS BUDGET CHAIR
FIFTEEN YEARS AGO AND WE STILL
HAD OPEN STATE HOSPITALS FOR
PEOPLE WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES AND 80% OF OUR
MONEY FOR DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WANT TO THE 20%
THAT WERE IN THE STATE
HOSPITALS AND 20% OF THE MONEY
WENT 280% OF THE PEOPLE THAT
WERE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL ONE
USED REGIONAL CENTERS AND ITS
THE STATE HOSPITALS CLOSED. THE
MONEY DID NOT FOLLOW TO THE
LOCAL AREAS AND WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS REALLY TAKE US VERY FAR
ON TE PATH TO DO WHAT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN DONE AT THE TIME THAT
THE STATE HOSPITALS CLOSE
ADDITIONALLY THIS LEGISLATURE
ADOPTED THE OPTION OF SELF
DETERMINATION PLANS AND I
BELIEVE IT WAS EIGHT YEARS AGO
FOR PEOPLE IN LOCAL REGIONAL
CENTERS THIS BILL CREATES AN
OMBUDSPERSON THAT WILL WORK
WITH FAMILIES TO EXPEDITE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT BILL
THAT HAS NOT MOVED RAPIDLY OVER
EIGHT YEARS. THIS IS AS MUCH
PROGRESS ON THIS ISSUE AS WE
HAVE HAD IN DECADES WE ALL
SHOULD BE PROUD TO VOTE FOR
THIS BILL I ASKED FOR AN IPHONE.
THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SINGMAN CENTER CAN
REMAKE INCLUDES I AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE ON THE
FLOOR AND I ASKED FOR A VOTE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. HI ATKINS. FIVE
BASS. FIVE BECKER HI FORTUS
FIVE BRADFORD HI CABALLERO AYE
COURTESY FIVE DALLY. HI DODD HI
DURAZO HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER FIVE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG
FIVE HUESO HI HER TADO I JONES
HI KAMLAGER HI LAYERED HI LEYVA
HI LIMóN HI MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ HI MEN. HI NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF THOSE. HI
PAN HI PORTANTINO HI RALPH I
RUBIO HI SKINNER AYE STERN HI
I'M BURKE. I LIKE ASKING AYE
WIENER AYE WILK. HI HIGHS FORTY
NO ZERO THE BUDGET BILL IS
APPROVED MEMBERS ARE WAITING
FOR A COUPLE OF BUDGET BILLS TO
COME FROM THE ASSEMBLY SO WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON WITH MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE
DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. HE'S GOT OBJECTION THE
SENATE JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF
JUNE TWENTY FIRST THROUGH THE
TWENTY FOURTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WILL BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED
BY THE MINUTE KIRK. CENTER
HERTZBERG THANK YOU UNDER
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS TO REQUEST
THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE. FILE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
THREE WHICH IS A. B. SEVEN OH
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY.
TO THE INACTIVE FILE PLEASE
THANK YOU. ORDERED. THE SENATOR
LEYVA THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AT THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SIX AJ ARE FOURTEEN FROM
THE SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR
FOR PURPOSES OF AMENDMENT. TO
ORDERED. STILL UNDER MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES
ANYONE ELSE. SEE NON
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING FILE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE SIXTY TWO WITH
AMENDMENTS 503-700-1390 ONE
ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR SEVENTY
THREE FOUR SEVENTY FOUR SENATE
BILL SIX ELEVEN NINE THIRTY
EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER BILL
THREE SEVENTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS SIX THIRTY SIX SIXTY
THREE WITH AMENDMENTS. EIGHT
EIGHTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS.
740-678-8901. FOURTEEN SEVENTY
FIVE THREE FIFTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS SIX THIRTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS TO FOURTEEN FIFTY
FIVE WITH AMENDMENTS ELEVEN A
ONE WITH AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TWO WITH AMENDMENTS
FOR NINETY SIX. TEN EIGHTY FOUR
WITH AMENDMENTS SECOND READING
WILL BE DEEMED READ THANK YOU
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS-
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR
BURGESS. SENATE AG COMMITTEE
WILL MEET UPON A GERMAN IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE. SENATE
AG WILL MEET UPON ADJOURNMENT
IN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
SENATOR RICHARD. MCGUIRE BUT
YOU ALL MOVED SO AND I'M I'M
STRUGGLING TO FIND PEOPLE.
SENATOR ALAN MEMBERS- JUST
ANNOUNCEMENT THAT THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENT
QUALITY WE MEETING UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF THIS SESSION UP
IN FORTY TWO OR THREE VERY GOOD
SENATOR EQ AT MADISON IT IS
COMMITTEES EQ COMMITTEE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE UPON
ADJOURNMENT CENTER WIENER. VIA
A PUNDIT GERMAN THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE WILL MEET ON THE
SENATE FLOOR VERY GOOD HOUSING
HERE IN THAT IN THAT CHAMBER.
SENATOR MCGUIRE THANK YOU SO
MUCH A MATTER PRESENT IN THE
MORNING I TWENTY MINUTES UPON
ADJOURNMENT OF THE AG COMMITTEE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE WILL
MEET IN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE.
VERY GOOD. GOVERNMENT FINANCE
IN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE TWENTY
MINUTES AFTER THE AG COMMITTEE
ADJOURNS. VERY GOOD WE HAVE A
BUSY AFTERNOON SO- MOST OF US
WILL BE AROUND FOR THAT MEMBERS
ARE GOING TO MOVE ON TO. OUR
RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS WHERE WE'RE GOING
TO GO AHEAD AND TAKE UP THE
ADJOURNING MEMORIES- WHILE
WE'RE HERE. SENATOR PORTANTINO.
THANK I COULD ASK EVERYBODY TO
SIT DOWN WE'RE GOING TO BEG
WE'RE GONNA START DOING OUR
JOURNEY MEMORIES. AND THIS
WOULD BE AN APPROPRIATE TIME TO
SHOW RESPECT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MCGUIRE. TURNING MEMORIES. OKAY
YEAH. CENTER PORTANTINO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE IN TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A VERY
DEAR FRIEND OF MINE- HELEN AND
WEALTH- WHO PASSED AWAY THIS
PAST MAY AFTER A SHORT BATTLE
WITH CANCER. AND AS SHE WAS
ALWAYS KNOWN WAS BEST KNOWN FOR
VOLUNTEERING IN BEING A FIERCE
COMMUNITY ACTIVIST IN THE
PASADENA AREA. SHE SERVED ON
MORE COMMUNITY COMMITTEES THAT
I HAVE TIME TO MENTION AND HER
LEGACY IS VISIBLE THROUGH THE
ENTIRE REGION. BUT I'D LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW THINGS THAT
MADE AND SO SPECIAL. SHE WORKED
AS A MEMBER OF THE YWCA
PASADENA FOOTHILL VALLEY BOARD
OF DIRECTORS IMPLEMENTING ITS
MISSION OF ELIMINATING RACISM.
AND EMPOWERING WOMEN. SHE
WORKED ON THE FORTY FIRST
ASSEMBLY DISTRICTS WOMEN'S
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. AND WAS A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF WOMEN'S CLUBS.
AND THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION
ON THE STATUS OF WOMEN. AND
ALSO AS A COMMISSIONER AND PAST
CHAIR OF PASADENA'S COMMISSION
ON THE STATUS OF WOMEN. SHE WAS
VERY ACTIVE WITH THE PASADENA
AREA LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS AND
ARE INTERESTED IN YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO ARE AGING OUT OF THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM WAS ONE OF HER
PASSIONS. SHE WAS PART OF ALL
SAINTS CHURCH FOSTER CARE
PROJECT SHE SERVED ON THE
STEERING COMMITTEE INCLUDING
TWO YEARS AS ITS CHAIR. THREE
YEARS AS A POINT PERSON FOR
LEARNING WORKS HIGH SCHOOL A
WERE LEARNING WORKS WHICH
EDUCATES CHILDREN THAT NEED OUR
HELP- AND SHE PROVIDED THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE IN CRISIS. AND
THOSE PREVIOUSLY INCARCERATED
OR LIVING ON THE STREETS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA. FOR OVER TWENTY
YEARS AND WORKED AT OCCIDENTAL
COLLEGE AND WAS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE OCCIDENTAL COLLEGE
BOOKSTORE FROM NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE UNTIL HER RETIREMENT IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN. SHE PLAYED
A KEY ROLE IN DRAFTING THE
GARMENT MANUFACTURERS CODE OF
CONDUCT. UNDER HER LADERSHIP
OCCIDENTAL COLLEGE'S BOOKSTORE
BECAME THE FIRST COLLEGIATE
RETAILER TO SELL CERTIFIABLY
SWEAT SHOP THREE COLLEGE
APPAREL. UNION CUT SO AN
IMPRINTED. IN TWO THOUSAND TEN
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY AND
WAS ONE OF MY WOMEN IN BUSINESS
HONOREES. FOR YEARS AND WAS
INVOLVED IN THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEMOCRATIC PARTY THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC CENTRAL
COMMITTEE AND SHE WAS HONORED
WITH REGIONAL DIRECTORS
OUTSTANDING SERVICE AWARD. BY
THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SHE WAS ONE OF THOSE ACTIVISTS.
THAT NEVER BACKED AWAY FROM THE
FIGHT BUT DID SO WITH SUCH A
QUIET CONFIDENCE THAT SHE
BROUGHT OTHERS AROUND WITH HER
GRACE AND DIGNITY THERE'S AN
OLD SAYING THAT'S BEEN
ATTRIBUTED TO ST FRANCIS THAT
SAYS. PREACH THE GOSPEL EVERY
DAY AND SOMETIMES USE WORDS
THAT WAS AN WALLEF SHE JUST IN
BODY THIS CLASS AND ITS DIGNITY
BUT NO ONE COULD EVER GET MAD
AT HER BUT THEY ALL JUST AGREED
AND MOVED SHE JUST AFFECTED
PEOPLE AROUND HER SO
POSITIVELY. THAT IT IS SUCH A
TREMENDOUS LOSS TO OUR DISTRICT
TO HAVE LOST THIS WONDERFUL
HUMAN BEING. THOUGH SHE'S
RECEIVE SO MANY HONORS AND SO
MANY RECOGNITIONS HER HIGHEST
HONOR WAS BEING A MOTHER TO
CINDY WHO JUST GOT ELECTED IN
HER OWN RIGHT SO SHE HAS A
POLITICIAN IN THE FAMILY AFTER
BEING SO ACTIVE IN POLITICS AND
CLINTON AND WIFE TO ROGER AND
GRANDMOTHER TO JULIET AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE JORDAN
HER MEMORY TODAY SO THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES. PLEASE BRING HER
NAME TO THE DESK SO THAT SHE
MAY BE APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE SENATE.
SENATOR HURTADO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
TURN IN THE MEMORY OF YEAH HE'D
TO SEE YEAR PROCESS YEAH YOU
PRESS WAS BORN ON JULY TWENTY
SIXTH NINETEEN NINETY TWO HE
IMMIGRATED TO THE UNITED STATES
IN SEARCH OF THE MERICAN DREAM
FOR MEXICO IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS AND STARTED HIGH
SCHOOL HERE. BUT NOT LONG AFTER
HE STOPPED SCHOOL AND BEGIN
WORKING TO INSTALL FLOORS TO
PROVIDE FOR AND CARE FOR HIS
FAMILY. MORE RECENTLY. HE HAD
RETURNED TO SCHOOL TO EARN HIS
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA THROUGH
DETERMINATION AND PERSEVERANCE
HE DID JUST THAT GRADUATING
WITH A STEP DAUGHTER AND THE
REST OF THE CLASS OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. DATE ALWAYS MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE WAS
PERFECTLY TAKEN CARE OF HE
ALWAYS. MADE JOKES AND TRIED TO
MAKE PEOPLE SMILE HE LOVES
SPENDING TIME WITH HIS FAMILY.
LOVES CARS AND LOVES DRIVING.
HE LEAVES BEHIND HIS WIFE AND
THREE STEP CHILDREN. I ASKED
THAT WE TAKE THIS MOMENT TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF THE AGE.
PLEASE BE BRING HIS NAME TO THE
DESK SO THAT HE HE CAN BE
APPROPRIATELY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE SENATE. SENATOR GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TODAY
A RISE TO JOIN IN MEMORY OF
PATRICIA PADDY O'SULLIVAN
TRAVNIK A LIFELONG RESIDENT OF
WEST LONG BEACH. PATTY WAS BORN
IN NINETEEN FORTY TWO IN LONG
BEACH CALIFORNIA SHE GREW UP IN
WEST LONG BEACH WHERE SHE LIVED
WITH HER FAMILY AND ATTENDED
POLY HIGH SCHOOL. ON JULY
TWENTY SEVENTH NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT SHE MARRIED HER DEAR
HUSBAND NICHOLAS AND SOON AFTER
WELCOME TO TEACH CHILDREN AT
LONG BEACH MEMORIAL HOSPITAL.
SHE WAS A CHAMPION FOR THE
COMMUNITIES OF THE WEST SIDE
AND SERVED AS A PROUD FIELD
DEPUTY FOR THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH'S SEVEN COUNCIL DISTRICT
FOR MANY MANY YEARS IN FACT I
WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH HER.
SHE WAS KNOWN FOR DRIVING THE
NEIGHBORHOOD DALY TO SPOT
SIDEWALKS AND STREETS THAT
NEEDED REPAIRS AND TO VISIT
WITH NEIGHBORS WHO ALL LOVED
HER. SHE LATER RETIRED AND
WELCOMED HER FOUR GRANDCHILDREN
ELLA ABE INGRID AND LEVI. SHE
WAS A DEVOTED AND BELOVED
GRANDMOTHER WHO IS KNOWN SIMPLY
AS GIGI. PATTY WAS A TIRING
BEAUTY A ONE IN A MILLION WOMAN
AND A FORCE OF NATURE. SHE
WOULD SAY THAT IN HER LIFE SHE
WAS MOST PROUD OF HER FIFTY TWO
YEAR MARRIAGE. HER MOTHER HOOD.
AND THE FIERCE LOVE SHE HELD
FOR HER FAMILY. PATTY DIED
SUDDENLY IN HER HOME ON JUNE
SIXTEENTH OF THIS YEAR. SHE IS
SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND NICOLAS
FOR CHILDREN DAVID AND BRIDGET.
HER DAUGHTER IN LAW MERRI. HER
GRANDCHILDREN ELEANOR ABRAHAM
INGRID AT LEVI AND HER BROTHER
PATRICK BURKE. CHIU BE GREATLY
MISSED BY HER FAMILY TAKES
COMFORT. THAT SHE HAS JOINED
HER MOTHER AND FATHER WHOM SHE
ADORED. I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
WE ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY AND
OFFER OUR SINCEREST CONDOLENCES
TO HER FAMILY. MANY OF WHOM ARE
MY FRIENDS THANK YOU. PLEASE
BRING FORWARD. THE NAME SO THAT
WE MAY APPROPRIATELY
MEMORIALIZED. MEMBERS WE ARE
HAVE THE. THE- BILLS HERE AT
THE DESK THE. THERE IS A
MESSAGE FROM THE ASSEMBLY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. MADAM
PRESIDENT I AM DIRECTED TO
INFORM YOUR HONORABLE BODY THAT
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDED AND ON
THIS DAY PASSED AS AMENDED
SENATE BILLS ONE FIFTY ONE ONE
FIFTY SEVEN AND SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTY NINE AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR HONORABLE BODY TO
CONCURRENCE THAT AMENDMENTS TO
PARKER CHIEF CLERK OF THE
ASSEMBLY ABOVE BILLS ORDERED
TWO UNFINISHED BUSINESS FILE.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
SENATOR MELENDEZ. OKAY. RENDON-
MELENDEZ FORAGERS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- PURSUANT TO
SENATE RULE TWENTY EIGHT AND
MAKING A MOTION TO WITHDRAW
SIERRA FIVE FROM THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COMMITTEE BROUGHT TO THE SENATE
FLOOR THAT WE CAN HAVE A DEBATE
IT IS NOW BEEN FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE DAYS SINCE THE
GOVERNOR DECLARED A STATE OF
EMERGENCY FOR KEVIN SHUT DOWN
THE STATE SINCE THEN WE'VE LOST
NEARLY THREE MILLION JOBS.
THREE MILLION JOBS GAS MARCH OF
LAST YEAR WAS THREE DOLLARS AND
FIFTY SIX CENTS TODAY IT'S-
UPWARDS OF EIGHTY DURING CLOSE
TO FIVE DOLLARS IN MANY PARTS
OF THE STATE- UNEMPLOYMENT IS
SEVEN POINT NINE PERCENT. TODAY
80% OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR A VACCINE CAN GET.
ONE- I DON'T SEE THE REASON TO
CONTINUE THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
I THINK AS I'VE SAID A MILLION
TIMES ON THIS FLOOR IT'S TIME
WE STEP BACK INTO OUR ROLES AS
LEGISLATORS AND DRIVE THE SHIP.
INSTEAD OF LETTING THE GOVERNOR
DRIVE THE SHIP EVERY DAY I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. SENATOR
HERTZBERG THANK VERY MUCH
JOURNAL ASTRONOVA. MADAM
SECRETARY AT SENATOR HERTZBERG
ASK FOR A NO VOTE CENTER
MELENDEZ AS FOR AN AYE VOTE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. NO ARCHULETA NO
ATKINS NO BUT BASS. HI BECKER
NO FORTUS. BRADFORD NO CUT BY
ADAM NO CORTES HE- NO DALLY HI
DODD. NO TORONTO. NO EGGMAN. NO
GLAZER NO GONZALEZ NO GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG. NO WAY SO NO HER
TADO NO JONES HI KAMLAGER NO
LAYERED NO LEYVA. NO LIMóN NO
MCGUIRE NO MELENDEZ HI MEN NO
NEWMAN- NO NIELSEN. HI OCHO
ALTHOUGH HI TAM NO PORTANTINO.
NO ROTH. NO RUBIO NO SKINNER.
NO STERN. NO I'M BURKE NO WAY
CASKEY NO WIENER. NO WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
PORGES. HIS EIGHT KNOWS THIRTY
ONE THE MOTION PASSED- FAILS
THE MEMORY THE MOTION FAILS.
MEMBERS ARE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO- UNFINISHED BUSINESS THE
SENATE SUPPLEMENTAL FILE NUMBER
ONE. ITEM NUMBER ONE TWENTY
SEVEN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY ONE
BY THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT
RELATING TO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND MAKING AN
APPROPRIATION THEREFORE TO TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED
TO THE BUDGET. CENTER SKINNER
THE FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SO THIS
TRAILER BILL SB ONE FIFTY ONE
IS ANOTHER THAT WILL HELP IN
OUR ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
HELP BUILD CALIFORNIA BACK AS
WE RECOVER FROM THIS PANDEMIC.
AND WHAT IT DOES IS MAKE
STATUTORY CHANGES TO- FOR
EXAMPLE CREATE THE CALIFORNIA
COMPETES GRANT PROGRAM WHICH
PROVIDES GRANTS TO INCENTIVIZE
BUSINESSES TO. MAKE INVESTMENTS
IN CALIFORNIA AND COMMIT TO
CREATING AT LEAST FIVE HUNDRED
JOBS IT ALSO CREATES THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM FUND TO
PROVIDE MICROGRAMS TO SMALL
SMALL BUSINESSES SO YOU KNOW WE
HAVE A GREAT WE'VE HAD A GREAT
PROGRAM GIVING GRANTS TO WHAT
WE CONSIDER SMALL BUSINESSES
BUT MOST- ENTERPRISES BEGIN
WITH A SINGLE PERSON AND SO
THESE MICRO ENTERPRISES. ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO HELP SUPPORT
AND THAT'S WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM FUND DOES THE- THE BILL
ALSO X. A PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO OUR GRANTS THAT WE
HAVE ALREADY HAD ESTABLISHED
FOR OUR- INDEPENDENT VENUES
MEANING ARE PERFORMING ARTS
CULTURAL ARTS MUSIC VENUES AND
SUCH. AND OUR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT GRANTS FOR SMALL
NONPROFIT PERFORMING ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS THE BILL PROVIDES
RELIEF ECONOMIC SECTORS THAT
HAVE BEEN VERY IMPACTED BY THE
PANDEMIC. AND SUPPORTS OUR JOB
GROWTH IN THE STATE THROUGH
INCENTIVES FOR INVESTMENTS AND
JOB CREATION AND PROGRAMS TO
SUPPORT INCLUSIVE
ENTREPRENEURSHIP IN WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. SENATOR
ALAN. MEMBERS SAID THERE'S LOTS
TO CELEBRATE IN OUR BUDGET THEY
HAVE BEEN DESCRIBED BY SO MANY
OF OUR COLLEAGUES I JUST WANT
TO POINT OUT THAT THIS%
PARTICULAR BILL DOES SOME
IMPORTANT WORK IN HELPING TO
PROTECT OUR ARTS AND CREATIVE
AND CULTURAL ECONOMIES HERE IN
CITY CALIFORNIA THAT REALLY HAS
BEEN DECIMATED BY THE PANDEMIC
LIKE SO MANY PARTS OF OUR
ECONOMY BUT THE ARTS WERE
PARTICULARLY HARD HIT IT'S AN
IMMENSELY IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
ECONOMY VENUES WERE SHUT DOWN.
PERFORMING ARTS SPACES
GALLERIES ANY OF THE ARTS BRING
US TOGETHER AND OF COURSE THAT
INVOLVES A FOLKS PACKING IN THE
ROOM SOMETIMES IN AND THAT'S
JUST THE KIND OF ACTIVITY THAT
WE COULDN'T ENGAGE IN DURING
THIS PANDEMIC AND SO MANY OF
THESE CORE AN IMPORTANT
ORGANIZATIONS NONPROFITS.
VENUES AT CETERA WILL REALLY
DECIMATED BY THE PANDEMIC AND
ONE OF THE THINGS OF THIS BILL
DOES IS PROVIDE FUNDING. FOR
THOSE- THOSE INSTITUTIONS FOR
MUSEUMS AND FOR OUR CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL AND SO. ONE OF THE
MANY MANY THINGS TO CELEBRATE
IN THESE BUDGET. IN THIS BUDGET
TRAILER BILLS AND I- INTO THE
ETHICALLY ASK OUR COLLEAGUES TO
JOIN ME IN SUPPORTING THIS
PARTICULAR ONE. SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR PRESIDENT
I'M SORRY IN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE I ALSO
WANT TO ECHO THE SENTIMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES I
WANT TO PARTICULARLY FOCUS ON
D. UP CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT
PERFORMING ARTS CAMP PROGRAMS
THAT ALSO WILL HELP ARE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAPPENED JUST. DOWN IN THE LAST
YEAR AND THEY'RE DEALING WITH A
LOT OF ISSUES BUT I'M REALLY
PLEASED TO SEE THAT WE'RE
INVESTING IN THE SECTOR THESE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS ARE
REALLY THE HEART OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THEY PROVIDE ACCESS
TO THE ARTS TO THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THAT
STRUGGLE. TO SEE THAT IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AS A FORMER TEACHER
I CAN ATTEST TO THE FACT THAT
THESE ARTS PROGRAMS ARE
DISAPPEARING IN OUR SCHOOLS AND
SO WE NEED THESE ORGANIZATIONS
TO CONTINUE TO BE PARTNERS IN
THE EDUCATION OF OUR CHILDREN
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE ARTS IS NOT ONLY FOR THOSE
THAT ARE WEALTHY BUT TO EVERY
SINGLE INDIVIDUAL NO MATTER OF
THEIR ECONOMIC STATUS SO I ALSO
WHOLEHEARTEDLY WANT TO SUPPORT
THIS I ALSO KNOW THAT TAP WE DO
HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO IN
TERMS OF PROVIDING LONG TERM
SUPPORT. BUT I AM SO PLEASED TO
SEE THAT YOU KNOW WE WILL
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THESE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT RACE
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
PROVIDE SO MUCH FOR OUR FOR OUR
COMMUNITY SO WITH THAT I WILL
ALSO SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO FURTHER. OR
DEBATE. CENTER SKINNER YOU MAY
CONCLUDE. THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR THE COMMENTS FROM MY R.
COLLEAGUES I THINK MANY OF US
MOST OF US ARE LOOKING FORWARD
TO BEING ABLE TO RETURN TO. OUR
SMALL COMMUNITY THEATERS OUR
MUSIC VENUES AND OTHERS AND
THIS BILL AMONGST MANY OTHER
THINGS THAT SUPPORT THEM AND
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. HEADED SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI HI
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS. AYE BATES.
BAKER HI PORGES HI BRADFORD HI
CUT BY ADAM HI COURTESY. HI
DALLY. DODD HI TORONTO I EGGMAN
HI GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI HUESO FIVE
FURTADO HI JONES. KAMLAGER HI
LAYARD HI LEYVA HI LIMóN FIVE
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ. MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. FIVE HOTEL
OF BOTH. HI PAN HI PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI
STERN FIVE AMBERG HI BY CASKEY
HI WIENER AYE WILK HI IT'S
CALLED THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES DALLY. GROVE I. JONES
MELENDEZ. FIVE THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO THE AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED WITH THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED WITH
THE BEYOND ITEM NUMBER ONE
TWENTY EIGHT MADAM SIX
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL ONE FIFTY SEVEN BY THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT RELATING
TO THE BUDGET TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. CENTER SKINNER THE
FLOOR'S YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SO THE WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS ADDRESSES.
THE MISUSE OF STATE FUNDS BY
OUR CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION AND
REFLECTS OUR OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY IN THAT REGARD.
IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY
THE- CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
INSTIGATED ITS OWN AUDIT OF ITS
USE OF FUNDS IN IN THAT AUDIT
THE REPORT REVEALED THAT IT HAD
SUPPORTED ITS GENERAL FUNCTIONS
WITH RESTRICTED STATE FUNDS
THAT WERE INTENDED FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AND
WORKER SAFETY AND UNFORTUNATELY
THE AUDIT ALSO REVEALED THAT
THIS WAS A LONG STANDING
PRACTICE THAT HAD BEGUN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR. THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION NOTIFIED
OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
OF ADDITIONAL IMPROPERLY
TRANSFERRED AND UTILIZE STATE
FUNDS WHICH HAS RESULTED NOW IN
A DOJ INVESTIGATION. THIS
TRAILER BILL THEREFORE REMOVES
THE CDA FROM RECEIVING STATE
FUNDS IN FROM THE FOLLOWING
ACCOUNTS THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ENFORCEMENT TRAINING ACCOUNT
FIND THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ENFORCEMENT TRAINING PROGRAM
THE ENVIRONMENTAL CIRCUIT
PROSECUTOR PROJECT THE ASSET
FORFEITURE FUNDS AND HIGH
TECHNOLOGY THEFT APPREHENSION
AND PROSECUTION FUND. AND IT
PROHIBITS THE AWARDING OF THE
GRANT TO OR THE CREATION OF NEW
CONTRACTS WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S ASSOCIATION UNDER
THE SPECIFIED PROGRAMS WITHOUT
AYE ELSEVIER AYE VOTE. FOR ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. RIGHT CENTER NIELSEN.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE THIS IS
KIND OF A VINDICTIVE BELL GET
EVEN BILL IF YOU WILL. WE HAVE.
AN AGENCY ADD THAT REALLY HAS
HARMED. HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS. AND WE'RE
TAMPERING AROUND THE EDGES
RIGHT NOW TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
THE DVDS ACCESS IS I HOPE THAT
SOME LEGISLATION WILL COME
ALONG TO THE REST OF THIS YEAR
THAT IS ALIVE THAT CAN REFORM
DEBATE. THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
ASSOCIATION FOUND THEIR OWN
PROBLEM. THE DOORS THEIR OWN
AUTO. AND IMPLEMENTED THE
CHANGES THIS CRIED OF
DISMEMBERMENT AND REDIRECTION
OF MONEY SO LONG HAVE GONE TO
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY THE ASSET
SEIZURE MONEY FOR EXAMPLE IS
BEING RIPPED AWAY. AND GIVEN TO
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS. LIKE
COUNTY PA. I THINK THAT'S
INAPPROPRIATE IT IS IN
VINDICTIVE ATTEMPT HERE TO GET
EVEN WITH THE AGENCY. OUR
DEPARTMENT IF YOU WILL BUT NOW
IT'S KIND OF BEEN DISFAVOR
BECAUSE THEY SUPPORT. JUSTICE
NOT JUSTICE REFORM OR
DESTRUCTION WHICH IS GOING ON
WILDLY ABOUT NOW. NOW THERE ARE
SOME DISTRICT ATTORNEYS THAT
ARE GOING IN OTHER DIRECTIONS
RIGHT NOW. BUT THIS
ORGANIZATION DOES NOT DESERVE
THIS KIND OF TREATMENT. THEY
ARE THE BASTIONS OF JUSTICE AND
PUBLIC SAFETY IN CALIFORNIA I
URGE A NO VOTE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. THE THING
MAN CENTER SKINNER YOU MAY
CONCLUDE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
FOR MADAM PRESIDENT- I THINK
THAT ALL OF US WOULD AGREE THAT
WE HAVE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
OVERSIGHT OF STATE FUNDS AND
WHEN WE WHEN IT IS. REAL TO US
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THE SOURCE
OF INFORMATION IS IF THAT
INFORMATION IS VALID AND
LEGITIMATE THAT IN NTS ENTITY
HAS BEEN MISUSING STATE FUNDS
SINCE AS LONG AS BACK AS TWO
THOUSAND AND FOUR WE HAVE A
RESPONSIBILITY TO PROTECT THOSE
STATE FUNDS WHICH THIS BILL
DOES. WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES NO
BAKER. HI FORTUS NO BRADFORD HI
CUT BY ADAM I CORTESE HI DALLY
NO DODD HI THERE ARE CERTAIN HI
EGGMAN. HI PLEASE. GONZALEZ
HIGH GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG HI
HUESO. HI HURTADO NO JONES. NO
KAMLAGER HI LAYERED HI LEYVA HI
LIMóN HI MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ
NO MAN. HI NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN.
NO A SHOW OF BOTH. NO HAN AYE
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH FIVE RUBIO
HI SKINNER FIVE STERN HI I'M
BURKE. WHITE HOUSE SKI HI
WIENER. I WILK NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GLAZER I
AMBERG. HIS TWENTY NINE KNOWS
TEN B. ASSEMBLY MEMBER JR
CONCURRED WITH. MEMBERS MOVING
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY NINE BY
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW AN ACT
RELATING TO STATE EMPLOYMENT
AND MAKING APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY BILL RELATED TO THE
BUDGET. CENTER SKINNER THE FOR
YEARS. I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS SB ONE
FIFTY NINE IS AN IDENTICAL
MEASURE TO THE CCPOA M. O. U.
BILL. AB ONE FIFTY NINE THAT WE
PASSED ON MONDAY BY VOTERS
THIRTY FIVE TWO TWO. THE REASON
WE NEED TO TAKE UP THIS VERSION
IS TO AVOID CHAPTER RING OUT
ISSUES. WITH SB ONE FORTY TWO
WHICH IS THE M. O. U. BILL FOR
THE OTHER NINETEEN BARGAINING
UNITS. THIS MEASURE WILL ENSURE
THAT THE CHANGES IN
COMPENSATION FOR MEMBERS OF
CCPOA TAKE A FACT. TODAY JULY
FIRST. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN NO
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I BASS HI
BAKER. FORTUS HI BRADFORD.
BECAUSE I ADAM HI COURTESY. HI
DALLY HI DODD. HI THERE ARE SO
HI EGGMAN NO GLAZER NO GONZALEZ.
HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI WITH
SO HI HER TADO I JONES I
KAMLAGER. LAYARD HI LEYVA FIVE
LIMóN HI MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ
AYE MILLION AYE NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN FIVE BUT CHAU BOTH. HI
PAM HI PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI STERN HI
AMBERG. WHITE HOUSE SKI HI
WIENER NO WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. FACTOR.
BRADFORD. GROVE KAMLAGER NO.
AMBERG HI. FIVE THIRTY TWO
KNOWS FIVE THE ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED WITH.
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR ATKINS THE DESK IS
CLEAR. ADAM MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK TODAY I
HOPE YOU HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND
AT HOME CELEBRATING OUR
NATIONS BIRTH- THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION WILL BE MONDAYJULY
FIFTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE AT TWO
PM. REPUBLICAN THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY
PM AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
PLACED WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY
AT TWO PM.